hey I'm Eric Porter I'm a professional
mountain biker and I'm going to show you
how to fix your bike in the field bikes
are better than they've ever been and
not much stuff breaks anymore but things
are going to happen and you need to know
how to take care of it yourself so you
can get home every now and then you'll
break a chain while you're riding
sometimes just because they're old or
assembled wrong or just grabbing too
many gears on the layup of steep climb
if you break your chain you're going to
want to pull off to the side of the
trail so you're not in the way and pull
out your tools on a multi-tool they
almost always have a chain tool as part
of it I like to use the design multi
tool that has basically everything I get
the biggest one that they have because I
go on big back country rides and I never
know what I'm going to need what you're
going to want to do is take off the
broken link so you can get a clean
reattachment in there if you have a
quick link you can simply put it
together pull it tight and it'll pop
back in as you're riding if you don't
have that you're going to need to push a
pin out to the outer plate and then put
the chain back together then drive the
pin back through to the right amount
there's three things that can cause a
flat tire those are puncture so that's
from like a thorn or something like that
there's a tear or rip in the side wall
and then there's pinch flatting which is
where you just basically smash a hard
edge really hard and it pinches your
tube so hard that it can puncture we're
going to need to pull off your tire and
you're going to want to feel all the way
through and see what caused your flat so
if you feel like a thorn sticking
through your need to get that out of
there before you put a new tube in there
and continue riding if you ran over
something super sharp and you actually
sliced your side wall or your tire you
need to prevent the tube from pushing
through that hole in the side wall a lot
of times I'll use a cliff bar wrapper
and you can put that in there and cover
the hole in the side wall and then you
can put a tube back in and it'll keep
the tube from popping back out
once you get practice stuff at home
fixing a chain or changing a flat tire
get out there and have some fun in the
backcountry
[Music]
[Music]